Welcome back everyone marvel and sony just
announced a new spider-man multiverse movie
so i'll explain what's going on and why it's such
a big deal after the events of spider man no way
home and the path they took to live-action
spider-verse multiverse crossover with tobey
mcguire and andrew garfield if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's still a lot of spider-man related stuff
happening this year in the movies between the
morbius movie with all those andrew garfield
toby maguire tom holland spider-man easter
eggs and crossover and spider-man across
the spider-verse with miles morales but
recently you probably saw sony announcing the new
madame web spider-man movie with dakota johnson
she's not somebody i would have expected when we
started hearing rumors about the movie last year
there are a couple versions of the character
but most of you are probably familiar with
the one from spider-man the animated series from
the 90s or from spider-man shattered dimensions
way to go boss you did well spider-man
i am proud of you the others can go home
but there is one more place that you
must visit where to now i think she
means my reality what am i gonna find
there more than you can ever imagine
i don't believe what you're telling me in your
reality i'm a character in fiction yep and i'm
an actor who plays you on tv if you don't remember
that episode it probably has my favorite stanley
cameo of all time because he literally finds
out that he's a fictional character inside
a tv show instead of story the larger spider-man
comics and goes to visit the real version of stan
lee at marvel comics they would be like tom hall
and spider-man finding out that he's a fictional
character and then going to meet the real kevin
feige inside marvel studios offices spider-man
it's time to go who is that exotic lady oh her
she's my ride i wonder how i'm supposed to get
down from here in fun fact that version of madame
web was actually voiced by stan lee's wife in real
life i could still hear the theme song from that
tv show in my head but during the events of those
series subsequent games madame web acts as sort of
a guardian of the multiverse or the spider-verse
with powers over reality similar to the beyonder
she tests different versions of spider-man to find
a team that's capable of stopping multiverse
villains in the spider-verse comics it's more
about the different versions of spider-man from
across the multiverse stopping the inheritors
the tv show version of that plot was a little
bit simpler with them all teaming up to stop
a version of carnage recently during spider-man
no way home toby maguire and andrew garfield's
versions of spider-man just came back because the
doctor strange's spell gone wrong the spell was
only meant to change reality for the main mcu
universe but because the way the spell worked
relying on aspects of reality the doctor strange
didn't fully understand yet yet that's going to
happen during doctor strange multiverse of madness
when spider-man messed the spell up the effects
of the spell bled into the whole of reality
everything in existence across the multiverse
pulling in anyone to the main mcu universe who
knew a version of peter parker was spider-man
and that's how toby mcguire and andrew garfield
wound up in the mcu along with their villains
because both toby maguire's peter parker and
andrew garfield's peter parker knew that they were
also spider-man the reason why a billion different
versions of peter parker spider-man didn't show up
was because doctor strange contained the spell
initially they started to pay that off though
at the end when reality started to tear and you
saw many characters showing up like they're all
coming i can't stop it they overwrote that first
spell with the second one which had the effect of
sending all those characters back to where they
came from it was sort of like a flex tape patch
on reality recently you also probably saw the
interviews where toby mcguire and andrew garfield
both said that they would love to come back as
their versions of spider-man and future movies
toby mcguire specifically said that his plot in
the movie in no way home left the door open for
more stories in the future revisiting you know
what what was part of my history and getting a
chance to like come together and a way to
revisit and just just to get to get back
into that and i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain resolutions
um and and just join in this like loving creative
spirit that's one of the reasons why he asked the
no way home writers not to go too deep into his
backstory after the events of spider-man 3 so
that they could save that story for future movies
but after no way home after the events of doctor
strange multiverse of madness marvel and sony kind
of need a new way to cross over between universes
and during no way home doctor strange was already
hardcore against messing with the multiverse with
reality before everything went off the rails in
the film you have to imagine that after doctor
strange too when the multiverse goes even crazier
that he'll be even more against doing something
similar and you also have to remember that all
the tobey maguire and andrew garfield's spider
man crossovers were only accidents he didn't bring
them to the mcu on purpose in fact he was trying
to prevent stuff like that from happening so
marvel and sony just need another easy way for
characters to cross over between universes in
a way that won't break reality and make doctor
strange really pissed off the easy solution that
they have to this problem in the animated spider
man across the spiderburst movie is spider man
2099's webware wristwatches that allow each of
them to travel the web of life and destiny at will
that's also right out of the comics too that's
the way they use in the spider-verse comics for
all the model crossover without breaking all of
reality if you're not familiar with those comics
or the web of life and destiny that's just another
way for versions of spider-man to perceive the
multiverse just because of their innate abilities
but it's the same thing we saw with all the
multiverse travel in spider man no way home it's
just using different tools for traveling between
universes in the announcement the sony and marvel
made about the madame web movie they mentioned the
original comic book version saying that because
she was so different in the comics they are going
to do something a little bit different with the
character like doing a younger version of her
dakota johnson obviously looks much younger than
the old version of madame web that most people
remember from spider man the animated series
and if you never read those original
madame web comic books in the comics
she didn't have control over reality she couldn't
travel the multiverse at will she was just more of
a supernatural doctor strange type of version of
spider-man it was more of a supernatural spin on
spider-man's abilities like she had clairvoyance
and prescience instead of the traditional spidey
sense she had astral projection telepathy sony and
marvel are saying that they'll be changing some of
those things and it makes it sound like they're
going to do more of a spider-verse shattered
dimensions character evolution for her character
like they're rolling hard on multiverse crossovers
now in the future after spider-man no way home
so they need a couple characters that can do that
my expectation right now is that they'll
just evolve her character the same way
they evolved the venom character in his movies
they'll start with a basic origin story using
a bunch of spider-man easter eggs and references
then eventually work up to full-blown multiverse
crossover with versions of spider-man in these
other sony spider-verse venomverse characters
the spider-man no way home post-credits scene with
venom is a good example that just teasing a bigger
storyline for the multiverse in the movies even
though he was only in the movie for a brief second
and left a piece of the symbiote behind you get
the idea they did a big multiverse spider-verse
crossover with all the characters because sony's
going to be the one making this madame web movie
my assumption initially is that early on she'll
mostly be crossing over with the other sony verse
venomverse characters and now that they've opened
the door to spider-man variants different versions
of peter parker with more on the way there'll
be more versions of spider-man and spider-woman
showing up eventually they have a bunch of movies
planned sony now has their pick of the litter
in terms of which version of spider-man that
they start referencing in some of these movies
so it doesn't always have to be tom holland's
spider-man that was one of the things he's been
talking about when he's been talking about
his future as spider-man in the mcu movies
could you would you do it again do you would
you put the suit on if given the opportunity
i mean i you know never say never i mean it's
such it's it's a character that's always gonna
be so meaningful to me and so beautiful to me and
again it comes back to service you know i think
if there's a way because that's what's that's
what that character is all about he's all about
serving the greater good and serving his fellow
fellow people his fellow you know serving humanity
and all life you know so if there's a way for me
to continue to add to the legacy of that character
in a way that feels like it's of service to
an audience of service to the themes of you
know the themes that stan lee kind of uh you know
injected that character with i'm open of course
i'm very very open the morbius movie is a good
example of this lots of tobey maguire spider-man
lots of andrew garfield spider-man and tom hall in
spider-man easter eggs like literally somebody at
sony said hey which version of spider-man should
we reference and everybody turned around and just
said yes like maximum spider-man easter eggs just
put every spider-man easter egg you've ever heard
of in this movie so we will start seeing more
actual spider-man stuff going on in all these sony
spin-off movies let me know in the comments though
which versions of spider-man do you want to see in
which of these movies and i'll do more videos
about the other sinister six spin-off movies
that they're currently making when we get more
details about those the craven movie with aaron
taylor johnson mcu quicksilver is the next big one
i cannot wait for all the memes when that shows up
there was a version of craven that showed up in
the tears of reality during the ending for spider
man no way home so they were kind of teasing the
future of the larger spider-man spin-off movies
like we're gonna be doing versions of all these
different sinister six multiverse characters that
you're seeing show up here sooner than you think
i explained who all those blue figures were in
my full spider man no way home breakdown video
so i'll add a link for that in the description
if you want to learn more about them and we will
be getting more morbius trailer videos with more
spider-man easter eggs soon it'll be fun to see
where they try to take that movie and yes i do
think that morbius will eventually cross over with
mcu blade sure you're ready for that mr whitman
everyone click here for my new morbius video
with all the andrew garfield easter eggs and
connections and click here for my new
marvel doctor strange 2 iron man video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!